and strategic view of the challenges of
migration and undermines international
cooperation rather than taking an
opportunity for the UK to show
leadership as we did in 1951.
there are too many problems for one
speech in this bill and
the right Reverend pellets the bishop of
a darum and Bishop Augusta will speak to
other issues
but I hope the government will listen to
the speeches today pointing out some of
the issues including the eloquent and
detailed speech by the noble Lord Lord
Coker
the existing Global conventions and
agreements need updating
in response to the crises we face today
while now inadequate what those
conventions offer is a baseline from
which to build a globally shared
understanding of what protection must be
given to refugees
they are not inconvenient obstructions
to get round by any legislative means
necessary
legal compatibility is a question for
the Learned lawyers among your Lordships
but it does not require a lawyer to see
that what is suggested is a dramatic
departure from what was ever envisaged
in international law since 1951.
even if this builds succeeded in
temporarily stopping the boots and I
don't think it will it won't stop
conflict or climate migration
the ipcc
forecasts that climate change by itself
let alone the conflicts it's already
causing will lead to at least 800
million more refugees
a year in total by 2050.
and what if other countries follow suit
the unhcr has warned that the bill could
lead
to the collapse of the International
System that protects refugees is that
what we want the United Kingdom's
contribution to be in our leadership
currently 80 percent of refugees are
still in the global South protected by
the poorest countries in the world
of course we cannot take everyone and
nor should we
but this bill has no sense at all of the
long-term and of the global nature of
the challenge that the world faces
it ignores the reality that migration
must be engaged with at source as well
as in the channel as if we as a country
were unrelated to the rest of the world
it is a siled bill not a whole of
government bill it does not drawing
conflict management and prevention which
drives migration it does not draw in
climate impacts which Drive migration
and conflict it is isolationist it is
morally unacceptable and politically
impractical to let the poorest countries
deal with the crisis alone and cut our
International Aid
nor is there any measure in this bill
for engaging with the criminal gangs of
traffickers directed directly and
offensively rather than trusting simply
to what appears to be the
unpredictability of Market forces as if
traffickers were rationally trained
economic actors and not appalling
criminals
there must be safe legal routes put in
place
as soon as illegal unsafe Roots begin to
be attacked we cannot wait for the years
that will take place before that happens
my lords this bill is an attempt at a
short-term fix
it risks great damage to the UK's
interests and reputation at home and
abroad let alone the interests of those
in need of protection or the Nations who
together face this challenge our
interests as a nation are closely linked
to our reputation for justice and the
rule of law and to our measured language
calm decision
and careful legislation
none of those are seen here
long-term globally coordinated Solutions
must be part of the way forward
this nation should lead internationally
not stand apart
I intend to table amendments at
committee stage which encourage this
longer-term thinking and collaborative
Focus including a plan for combating
traffickers and working with
International Partners to look at
updating the 1951 convention
nevertheless
I hope that this house will not support
Lord paddock's
excellent sympathetic and carefully put
Amendment
I agree with its sentiment but I also
believe that as lord kokara said it is
our duty to change not to throw out the
bill
and finally as one might expect from
these benches
in the New Testament in Matthew chapter
25 Jesus calls us to walk welcome The
Stranger
that call has been part of the history
and culture in this country for
centuries and was part of the drive for
the modern slavery Act
I urge the government to reconsider much
of the bill which fails to live up to
our history our moral responsibility and
our politically our political and
international interests